these five actors have rewarded
moviegoers with fully dimensional
characters
some drawn from real life
all of them larger than life
the blacklisted screenwriter dalton
trumbo
the resourceful astronaut abandoned on
mars
[Applause]
the vengeful frontiersman betrayed by
his companions
[Applause]
the brilliant and complicated co-founder
of apple
and one of the first people to undergo
gender confirmation surgery
here are the outstanding nominees for
performance by an actor in a leading
role
brian cranston trumbo
matt damon the martian
[Applause]
leonardo dicaprio the revenant
michael fassbender steve jobs
eddie redmayne the danish girl
[Applause]
and the oscar goes to
leonardo dicaprio
[Applause]
this is the first oscar and sixth
nomination for leonardo dicaprio
[Applause]
thank you thank you all so very much
thank you to the academy thank you to
all of you in this room i have to
congratulate the other incredible
nominees this year on for their
unbelievable performances
the revenant was a product of the
tireless efforts of an unbelievable cast
and crew i got to work alongside first
off to my brother in this endeavor mr
tom hardy
tom
your fierce talent on screen can only be
surpassed by your friendship off screen
to mr alejandro inuritu
as the history of cinema unfolds you
have forged your way into history these
past two years what an unbelievable
talent you are thank you to you and
chivo
for for creating a transcendent
cinematic experience for all of us thank
you to everybody at fox and new regency
in particular arnon milshon you were the
champion of this endeavor
my entire team i have to thank everyone
from the very onset of my career mr
cayton jones for casting me in my first
film mr scorsese for teaching me so much
about the cinematic art form to mr rick
yorn
thank you for helping me navigate my way
through this industry and to my parents
none of this would be possible without
you and my friends i love you dearly you
know who you are and lastly i just want
to say this
making the revenant was about man's
relationship to the natural world a
world that we collectively felt in 2015
as the hottest year in recorded history
our production needed to move to the
southern tip of this planet just to be
able to find snow
climate change is real it is happening
right now it is the most urgent threat
facing our entire species
and and we need to work collectively
together and stop procrastinated
procrastinating we need to support
leaders around the world
who do not speak for the big polluters
of the big corporations but who speak
for all of humanity for the indigenous
people of the world for the billions and
billions of underprivileged people who
will be most affected by this
for our children's children and for
those people out there whose voices have
been drowned out by the politics of
greed i thank you all for this amazing
award tonight let us not take this
planet for granted i do not take tonight
for granted thank you so very much